the noon to you both gentlemen sir
Richie let me start with you existing
shareholders are taking 300 million
dollars in cash out of the business as
part of this fundraising how much will
you be taking out of that well I've put
in you know close to a billion billion
dollars and and we own 80 percent of the
company so we'll be taking out right you
know 80 percent of that right and how
much of the list identity will virgin
group own on an ongoing basis post the
floatation will own 51% or potentially a
little bit more but but we will still
still keep control after the float now
this obviously comes not long after you
turned down a 1 billion dollar
investment from Saudi Arabia they
offered to put a billion dollars into
this venture why did you drop your
interest with with the Saudis well that
they were talking about investing in
Virgin Galactic and also virgin orbit as
far as this particular floats concerned
it it's just Virgin Galactic and I think
the reason we decided not to push ahead
with the Saudis has been well
well-documented we felt that the killing
of Khashoggi was unacceptable and that
it wouldn't be appropriate for us to
take money from them so when I was
approached to go down this route and we
you know well you can talk to shimoff
and see it from the other side but we
but we decided that this was a good room
for us to go as an alternative well sure
math let me bring you in at this point
the the business is valued at one and a
half billion dollars post IPO that's
looks pretty racy for a business that
has never made a penny in profits and
hasn't even launched its commercial
flights yet well I mean I think it's
important to ground this in what the
next few years will look like so you
know we have already 600 customers
they've already given us 80 million
dollars we have 2500 more people in the
waiting list that want to be
this is a business that will
commercialize in the next 12 months and
it's a business that will be profitable
by mid 2021 so what we're talking about
now is a company that is very similar to
other very compelling technology
businesses right at the foot of its
breakout growth and so from a
risk/reward perspective I actually find
it very compelling in fact so much so
that I asked Richard for the opportunity
to invest another hundred million of my
own money personally into the deal which
he let me so I actually think the risk
reward on this is really compelling
I mean Virgin Galactic is obviously in a
race with some very well-heeled
competitors the likes of Elon Musk Jeff
Bezos to do the first commercial space
flight launch what gave you confidence
your math at virgin wood would win this
particular race well in fact you know
when I start I called Richard and asked
to start to get to know the team there
was about nine months ago and in those
nine months you know my team and I did
the same level of diligence that we've
done when we've made some of our best
investments whether it's in Bitcoin or
Amazon or slack or when you know my team
and I helped build Facebook it was that
same level of technical precision that
we applied to understand why he would be
the first to actually do this and what
we saw was a business that was frankly
incredible now the other thing to keep
in mind is that beyond the technical
proficiency this will for many years be
capacity constrained meaning there are
many many many more people that want to
go to space then there is room to fly
them and so whether it's us or our
friends like Elon or our friends like
Jeff Bezos we will all be in service of
humankind's desire to travel into space
and I think that each of us will have a
chance to build a great business but
what I can tell you from my and my
team's perspective is that we have built
something and Richards team has built
something that will start
commercializing in less than a year and
we think is really best-in-class so
Richard you've had one or two bumps in
the roads along the way here in terms of
getting to this point how confident are
you that you will genuinely be able to
hit the targets that you've set for
yourself in terms of launching flights
we're confident I mean we this has been
a 14-year development program in the
last few months we put to to Virgin
Galactic spaceship into space five
people became astronauts and that's the
first five people and from American soil
since 2009 so you know it's I think we
are slightly ahead of our competitors as
far as putting people into space with
we're moving the whole operation to this
beautiful spaceport in New Mexico we'll
be doing some more test flights there
and then you know next year I'll be
going up and we'll start taking the
public up and but what this enables us
to do is to build many more spaceships
and mother ships and and ramp ramp up
the program because as Jamar said the
demand you know way way out ways supply
and the more the more spaceships we can
get the more we can you know and enable
people who want to go to space to have
that chance now you've had some not all
of your experiences with public markets
in the past have been particularly happy
would you have rather retained this
business as in the private sector would
you have preferred not to have had to
gone public well I've been in business
for 50 years and the first company out
to a public Virgin Records
we took public a year before the stock
market crash and we brought it back but
since then we've had tremendous success
in the public markets I mean for
instance the last two companies that we
took public Virgin America and Virgin
Money in England both have done
extraordinarily well and we've benefited
the shareholders and and and and they've
helped helped us grow so I think we know
you know how to run a public company we
get you know we get a great team in
place that are very capable of it and
yeah I feel confident and and and I
think it's an exciting company for the
public to be involved in our mouths very
briefly how quickly do a check to go on
there's always an appetite
sorry we're speaking past each other
what I would say is that I think that
this is a business that is really fairly
valued by 2023 according to our
projections it's a business that will do
almost 600 million in revenue and almost
50 percent profitability margins it's in
fact you know very similar to many of
the best run software companies but it
just happens to be a hardware company
that is in the business of space flight
so I think that within the investment
period that we've looked at which is in
the next four or five years it'll be a
very profitable highly valued business
and if I may just on this last point I
would like to say that there is always
an appetite for great consumer brands in
the public markets and the reality is
that this is one of those indelible
businesses run and founded by an
indelible entrepreneur and so I think
that this was not a decision about
whether to go public or not it was just
really a decision to allow the public
markets and public investors and the
public at large to celebrate something
that is really revolutionary and will be
an incredible business all right so good
leave with I'm afraid gentlemen thanks
very much free time Sir Richard Branson
Chamath pally happy tire thank you